so who's my guest this week it's nile
dimarco
from america's top model to
oscar-nominated film producer he's
become an ambassador for deaf pride
taking on the hearing world on his own
terms he's fourth generation deaf
choosing not to communicate vocally and
has long challenged the notion that
learning to sign can hinder the ability
to speak english
his memoir deaf utopia is a love letter
to american sign language explaining why
he doesn't think deafness needs fixing
you're going to hear why competing in
america's next top model was hell
and why he's pretty annoyed with will
smith
did you see the slap we're talking about
will smith of course here
oh i did in fact see it all i mean i
think everyone in the audience was quite
confused initially it seemed like a joke
or like a scripted bit
but no
soon as will smith started screaming my
interpreter let me know and everybody
went quiet and i thought
what are you doing stealing our
spotlight come on well yeah i was going
to say that must have been i mean were
you actually annoyed about that was
anyone frustrated in the the deaf
community because it really was the
thing
yeah certainly it was yeah it was it was
my first thought i felt like you know
this is such a historic moment and it
really felt like a moment for us and i
thought
at least let us have this one night but
you know it's very typical for hearing
people to want to saturn themselves and
ask us to just orbit them
nyle demarco welcome to the program it's
really good to have you on the show and
i should say we'll be speaking to each
other through an interpreter today but
what i wanted to start by asking you
right at the heart of your book the
title no less is what would a deaf
utopia look like to you
good morning
a deaf utopia i think for me
would certainly look like a place where
we all have complete access
which means a world inclusive of sign
language but also
with accessible features that make deaf
people feel like we can really connect
and belong on this planet what does that
mean i suppose what i'm asking is what
don't we have at the moment
well i'd say some of the things that we
don't have um just in general is a lack
of deaf culture awareness
so many people that i meet who are
hearing and conversation often remind me
that they don't know that deaf culture
exists they don't really realize that we
have a community and from their
perspective
deafness is a disability and couldn't
possibly be inclusive of a culture which
in fact is not true we have a language
which gives rise to culture
i think essentially that really starts
with their lack of awareness
you also mentioned there the need for
sign to be better understood or better
recognized are you talking about in a
deaf utopia everyone would be able to
have some kind of literacy
yeah i mean essentially i would love
that uh you know i i think that's
probably one of the biggest goals that
we really have as a community
you know sign language has incredible
benefits for hearing people and for deaf
people alike right in sign language we
can speak and communicate faster than in
english we can also talk through windows
and underwater how cool is that
yes it really is i haven't thought about
that at all um but yeah there are there
are other things i'll come to from some
of your stories about some of the
benefits people may not have realized
not least having a party at home without
your mum knowing because you could just
shut the door and and go for it uh and i
think some of those examples are amazing
yeah you know honestly we call that
hashtag deaf games
you know being from a deaf family is
incredible but it's also incredibly rare
and i think kids like me tend to abuse
it my mom being such a good sleeper was
really helpful for us when we wanted to
rage in four or five o'clock in the
morning i mean you mentioned your family
you're fourth generation deaf
what did that mean growing up in your
family with how you
learned to communicate and and the
culture around you
definitely
being born to an entirely deaf family
and having deaf parents meant that i had
access to language day one to be honest
i don't really remember first learning
to sign like many other people don't
really remember their first words either
it's something that i wanted to hear
your view on because we've just been
through a pandemic i mean we're still in
it in in lots of ways and people were
having to home school and then i imagine
for those children didn't have access to
to the deaf schools and to their to
their peers to the people that they were
used to being with
absolutely absolutely and it's a great
point it was a very large problem in the
community deaf schools all over were
faced with an entirely new issue of how
they bring the exposure to the parents
and how do they bring them in home
how do they provide access to language
and continue exposing them to our
culture and continue to give them not
only exposure to their role models but
also the ability to socialize having to
send those children home to a place
where they couldn't practice sign
was in many ways traumatic for so many
kids out there
and
an entirely new issue that we faced with
the pandemic you're absolutely right i
suppose the other thing as well and i
wonder if you had an experience of this
is everyone was wearing masks and a lot
of people still are
was that difficult for you during the
pandemic
definitely
definitely you know
for me in everyday life i depend on lip
reading often
you know and honestly lip reading is
certainly not the best way to
communicate if you look at any of the
statistics you see that even the best of
lip readers can only catch about 30
but suddenly with a mask i was at zero
so all of the guesswork was gone of
course it was frustrating but i think
all of us really were in this together
yes well it's lovely to be able to see
your face
[Laughter]
well guys happy to take those off for
sure and it's nice to be able to see
people's faces now yeah exactly and some
of the real expressions um i'm obviously
minded of the fact that a lot of people
really liked your face because you won
america's next top model uh that's a
that's something that we should bring up
but i wonder when
when going onto that program
were you thinking about how it was going
to work that you
don't talk
in the sense of how some people were
going to then find it to communicate
with you
absolutely absolutely it was honestly
one of the first things i considered i
remember when america's next top model
first reached out to me for the audition
i ignored it
you know of course
any type of reality tv show and
certainly a competition i felt like
wasn't going to be ready for a deaf
person i certainly had never seen one on
tv before
but you know they reached out multiple
times and finally i responded and said
are you really ready for a deaf
contestant in the first place
they said yes
so i started the journey but of course
it was tough i did have an interpreter
on set but only 10 of the time meaning
90 of the time i was lacking the ability
to really communicate fully
i don't think they really understood the
accessibility needs
that really came along with the deaf
contestant but also how to accommodate
and so much of it just comes with you
know reality tv shows the you know
psychological warfare the mind games you
know the causing drama to make better tv
and i certainly get that perspective but
i survived through four months of it and
would i do it again uh no i'd rather not
walk through hell
not walk through her why hell
well
i'll tell you four months i mean imagine
for four months you could only use
say spoken english for 10 of the time i
was texting back and forth with
everybody else which is incredibly
limited i mean think about how fast we
can text right it doesn't really carry
like a like a conversation so to only be
able to use your language about 10 of
the time you know your language that
gives you not only dignity but who you
are it's you know your self-confidence
your pride and your ability to express i
think that the minute you start to think
about that you would feel incredibly
isolated if that had been your
experience and yet you could also you
could also be forgiven to think
being a model is perhaps a good
profession in the sense of at least you
don't have to talk when you're doing the
modeling part
right right exactly
and to be honest with you it was an
incredibly isolating experience but
i think in the end i really was planning
for a result i was looking forward to
the end and not only to win for myself
but also to win for the community and to
be able to elevate the amount of
awareness of our culture and our
community
which i think really was more important
you know
honestly modeling as a deaf person
there's a lot of benefits right i come
from a very visual culture where we
study body language so it's definitely a
different level being able to study a
photographer and what they're looking
for and also to be able to emulate the
the poses i mean body language is really
what we're experts in
yeah you i'm now just thinking about how
i'm sitting what i'm giving off to your
hair i'm going to think this through a
bit more but it's one of those things
that must be it must be a bit of a
superpower
oh absolutely absolutely and if you take
a look at any of the articles out there
about deaf people's peripheral vision
you'll actually see that studies have
been done to show that it's enhanced
it's widened we actually see more and we
take more of the world and than hearing
people so yeah we're superheroes you'll
take that i'm sure and it's uh it's
something you know again to think about
a different way of seeing the world
and actually reading the world while
you're in it you also of course are
known for dancing with the stars and
music
it seems again if you haven't thought
about deaf the deaf world the deaf
culture is an incredibly important part
of of being in the world and it's that
experience i understand of feeling the
beat
well i mean personally do i feel if i
could if you're asking if i could feel
the beat on set i'll be honest i
couldn't hear or feel anything
so our rehearsals were pretty
interesting in that we had to practice
using other systems we would often use
larger studios that were quite wide open
and the system that peta and i developed
was counting it was just simple math but
we also shared a cue system that we
developed
for example
if peta tapped me that was say to begin
the routine a hand squeeze would mean
that we were going to switch a specific
formation or footwork scratch on my back
might have meant that i was late
so to the audience at home
of course nobody noticed but if you go
back and watch some of the reruns you'll
be able to catch some of those cues but
for some people they do talk about being
able to feel some of the b but you
couldn't feel anything
right it really just depends on where
you are
so my twin brother actually who is also
deaf is a dj if you can believe
has an
amazing brilliant professional setup
that's like something like 2 000 watts
it's absolutely insane
but on dancing with the stars i couldn't
feel anything like white he counted the
dj booth
but you know there was a moment
certainly
where we had a couple of nfl uh dancers
who came on which was really great and
the funny thing was they couldn't catch
their footwork right they just couldn't
get the timing right
and at the end
i couldn't hear any of it i couldn't
feel any of it and i was still able to
keep the math perfectly on time which is
kind of ironic right i'm the only one in
the room who can't hear and yet i
imagine yeah well congratulations
belatedly for that because it was
obviously a huge success as well but i
suppose what's been driving your work as
well to this point because you've been
working now as a producer as well oscar
nominated congratulations for audible on
on netflix
i mean that must have been quite the
night especially because of coda as well
winning
oh it was incredible it was incredible
and truly a watershed moment for our
community
if you consider that it's been 35 years
since we've had another member of the
deaf community takes to the oscar stage
it's really incredible
marley matlin's work in this industry i
mean really truly speaks for itself but
that night we had over 10 deaf people on
the red carpet
it was incredible to see that amount of
representation
and the wins that night i mean if you
consider three wins alone from dakota
was really groundbreaking
and i think it shows that the time is
now
it really feels that people it really
feels like people at home are really
hungry for our stories
and we're really looking to make this a
movement rather than a moment
i think right now we have to start
bringing deaf people in behind the
camera right which is so key to
authenticity because that truly is where
it begins yes although the oscars this
year also bring to mind something else i
was wondering did you did you see the
slap we're talking about will smith of
course here
oh i did in fact see it all i mean i
think everyone in the audience was quite
confused initially it seemed like a joke
or like a scripted bit
but no
soon as will smith started screaming my
interpreter let me know and everybody
went quiet
and i thought
what are you doing stealing our
spotlight come on well yeah i was going
to say that must have been i mean were
you actually annoyed about that was
anyone frustrated in the the deaf
community because it really was the
thing
yeah certainly it was yeah it was my
first thought i felt like you know this
is such a historic moment and it really
felt like a moment for us and i thought
at least let us have this one night but
you know it's very typical for hearing
people to want to saturn themselves and
ask us to just orbit them
yeah although i'm also now trying to
imagine your interpreter um telling you
what will smith was saying and you
getting that uh as well because if you
could hear it and see it it was
as you say you didn't believe it
no absolutely
absolutely so during the oscars they had
two large tv screens on both sides and
so i was able to see will because they
had panned over to him and i could
clearly see a reaction of what was going
on but when i asked my interpreter what
he was saying it became very evident
that it was not a scripted bit at all
yeah and you definitely didn't need to
be able to hear to to understand the
last bit right talking about body
language
right definitely definitely immediately
and i could lip read them on the on the
cameras as well it was loud clear it was
yeah well quite at the moment but as you
say quite at the moment for the deaf
community as well that night and um i
know that you also feel very
passionately you say about people behind
the camera but also on the camera you
are of the view that deaf actors should
be playing the the deaf roles absolutely
definitely definitely
i mean
i don't think that uh deaf people only
ever have to play deaf roles certainly
but i think that auditions should be
open to everyone including members of
our community and i think we're at a
point where
we shouldn't be hiring hearing people to
play a deaf role certainly
so many people i think assume that it's
easy to take on the role of a deaf
person
but can they actually
really go in there and kill the audition
i don't think so right oftentimes people
are learning sign language a few minutes
ahead of time and you know sign language
takes years and years and years to be
able to really become fluent in but also
there's a cultural nuance that's really
ingrained in us that i think really
shows on screen i had a son a few years
ago and we went to a baby sign class and
the reason the woman had started the
class was because her sister was deaf so
she had signed her whole life
and it was an amazing way to communicate
with your child and and you know we we
are not deaf but i greatly enjoyed the
class it's fantastic
a lot of people i don't think really
realize that we have a lot of apps
available right we have the asl app
which i was thrilled to work on that
provides sign language right that can
teach you a little bit not only about
our language but also culture technology
really is amazing it really is just
talking about children um
there is someone you quote in the book
uh about
this whole area around uh generations
and the way that that this is or
shouldn't be talked about and has been
in the past you quote the view of the
man who painted in the first telephone
alexander graham bell who despite
marrying a deaf woman didn't believe
deaf people should marry each other
because of the risk of deaf children why
did you include that in the book
i included it i think because it's
important for hearing people
to read and really understand that deaf
issues are not
new
right that language deprivation did not
arrive recently
but this has been centuries and
centuries of oppression
and deprivation
you know in my book i really work to
outline the events sort of of our
history and bring those to modern day
which i think a lot of people don't
realize but of course what he was saying
you know as as horrible and unpalatable
as it is to hear i'll to say i should
say certainly in this
was a lot of the the people's view at
the time and may continue to be and i
just wondered as your fourth generation
uh within a family like that you know
what what is your
message on that point and and also how
has it made you think about your future
i would say to be honest with you i i
would be open to marrying a deaf or a
hearing person right you know i think
what's really important is sort of that
connection but you know i think we
should all trust our kids and certainly
ourselves to know that when we fall in
love it's it's right
you know i don't think that we should
certainly you know i mean love is not
expensive right but it's you know
available to all of us i think i mean i
suppose that the other question there is
around is around children i mean you may
not have got that far and i'm not
meaning to pry
but but when you think about uh if if
you think about such things
do you ever think about that like their
lives and how you would want their lives
to be with your own experiences and with
your siblings
so i'll tell you you know a big part of
deaf culture is that we want to be able
to pass it on like any of our cultures
right we want to be able to give our
children that sense of community you
know i would love to have a deaf child
but
you know i think i would really want my
children to know the culture to know the
community to share our language
right that beautiful world that i was
lucky enough to grow up in i would of
course want to pass that on and i would
want them to carry that same torch i
recognize this is a strange question
because i i'm not comparing the two but
i sometimes i'm an only child i get
asked would you have liked siblings and
how was that as if it was awful but it's
the only thing i know so i can only say
i'm okay
it was great you know i i i was okay but
i was going to ask you
because i think people are curious about
this do you think that it is a better
way to live without hearing because you
seem to have got so much from your
culture i i typically tell people i
truly don't know any different much like
you right i grew up entirely deaf and so
i don't really have a concept of of
sound or silence i mean i can't hear
waves but i think they're really
beautiful and so i think our
interpretations are just a little bit
different and our experience of those
are different
but i can tell you
you know i of course would love to meet
and work with even more deaf people who
want to come to the dark side i guess
that's why you're putting it
have you ever i don't know if it is
possible for you have you ever been
interested in trying any of the
technology to help you here
well funny enough a lot of people don't
know i actually used hearing aids
growing up
but i hated them not gonna lie i
absolutely load them the sound used to
give me the worst headaches and my
brother who's deaf loves djing right in
his car he's got an insane sound system
he will crank it so loud to the point
where your entire body is shaking and
within 5-10 minutes i'm like
bro bro bro you got to kind of know
because it's so unfamiliar to me that i
seriously i end up with a migraine so
but that's just me personally there's a
lot of deaf people out there who i think
can relate to it and might not be able
to how interesting i had no idea that
that they could give you a headache you
know in the bid to help you here
yep
that's just i guess how my hearing works
well it's fascinating because you know
there are those videos you will have
seen them of a child hearing for the
very first time uh and you know i
suppose there is that narrative that
then goes along with those sorts of
videos about that being a miracle and
that being the goal
i think a lot of people out there are
very misinformed on the experience of
deaf people right people love those
videos
they love them they're supposed to feel
great
but
it's a few seconds of another human's
life if you consider it right
you know
when i consider how i go about my day
and all of the things that are required
for a baby to be able to hear for the
first time those two things are very
different right what's important is not
the ability to hear what's important is
the access to language right and those
are two very different things
just because you can hear something like
i could with hearing aids doesn't mean
that i would have access to language
right
of course it's cute but i always want to
ask people okay you have this child
who's now have who's now had a hearing
aid or a cochlear put in what sort of
resources are you going to provide them
for the long term
is there a phrase or a word that you
think is far better in sign
than spoken
oh
any phrase or words
um
oh i'd have to think about that
i'd have to um
oh you know what i have to say my
favorite sign is monster it always has
been
and i just think it looks really cool
you know it means so many things but
it's also slang in the deaf community
you know it means like dope or like good
job right we'll say like ah monster i
love it
can we can we see it again
yeah okay great it's good this is this
is this is a lesson i always i love
knowing what people's favorite phrases
and words are so why not ask about sign
right right no definitely and
you know monster is like a it's like a
generational slang
so it's been around you know the let's
say maybe you know young kids older kids
maybe they won't know exactly but for
you know my age group they all know like
that's our thing that's like our you
know i don't know it's a millennial
thing we all kind of made it up
i feel i've been welcomed in to the crew
the monster crew briefly it's lovely to
talk to you
and um thank you thank you very much
it's been a real pleasure thank you so
much and i've had a great time with you
i hope to do this again that would be
great and thank you i should say for
being with us until we meet again take
care and goodbye
[Music]
you